We have observed 25-year-old granddaughter that seems to have some struggles.
Has issues with eating, repeating her words, anxiety, had a meltdown, maybe have history
of vaping, supposed to be doing Candida clans as an itchy area on the back of her neck,
spreading to scalp and any suggestions for low-income health, for chiro-functional medicine.
Okay, so we'll fully understand that question, but issues with eating, issues with repeating
her words, anxiety, had a meltdown, I suppose that means an emotional meltdown.
We have vapied, so vapied, what does that pertain to anything with the history?
Well, it pertains to tons of toxins, so there's a lot of heavy metals, a lot of poisons
in that vaping products that people are using, so that can lead to toxins.
Going back to the symptoms, I don't have anything close to complete history of this person,
but issues with eating, repeating her words, that was a key phrase to be, anxiety,
an emotional meltdown, then speak to neural inflammation, so that's the thing I would
look at. History of vaping, maybe other sources of toxins, you think of possible toxicity
to her brain. Supposed to do a Candida clans because she has an itchy area on the back of her neck,
spreading to scalp, can need to be one of the first things I think of, unless she had other Candida
symptoms. Certainly, you could have lots of different comorbidities. When we get ill, it's usually not,
here's the problem, we'll just take this out or fix this and now all my problems go away.
When we get ill, it tends to be a domino effect and multiple things go bad, so a person can have
parasites and heavy metals and Candida issues and toxicity to their brain and they can have all these
things that are going on at the same time, but usually that's what happens, that brings us, our bodies
are pretty resilient, but it's when we get this combination of all these things, breaking down,
there are barriers that overwhelm our immune system, that can lead to cancer, that can overwhelm
our body and can lead to autoimmune diseases, where our immune system starts making antibodies
against self-tissue. If you have to start to uncover the layers with any type of disorder, you're
just kind of breaking down the layers and cleaning things up. So, I'm not a functional medicine doctor
who thinks everything begins in the gut and everything is solved by this because the best way to know
what's going on is to run some labs and run some tests, but like this question mentioned, a lot of
people are in the situation, they don't have money for labs, I don't have money to do this stuff,
I don't have money to make a case review with you and get started on a call.
Well, that's where we have our courses, our courses are $50, so doing the autoimmune course for
$50, we're constantly adding more material and more information where you can start going through
some videos and learning how to take care of yourself is the best way to go.
Probably there's a lot of people that are in this situation, don't have the motivation to want
to take care of themselves. Well then, I don't know what to do in that situation. Hopefully that
this person, 25 years old, is getting to a bottom where they want to start
taking self-responsibility. It's very difficult when you have a person that doesn't want to take
responsibility for themselves hard enough with a kid who you're trying to force into a dietary
program that they're not willing to do. It's certainly impossible when a person is an adult,
so they have to be willing to do something, so you could lead them to some information. So if you
enjoyed one of our courses, you enjoyed our autoimmune course, you share information with them
from a grandparent to a grand child, I don't know how open or really they're going to be
to receive you that information, but I'd start with just uncovering things.
And the way to uncover things is to, first of all, try to decrease the toxic, toxic load
this person is dealing with. Sometimes when you just start decreasing the toxic load,
the body has an unbelievable way to heal. Meaning, are there inflammatory foods that this person's
eating that they need to get rid of? Is there support with detoxification pathway? Stop
vaping, stop their poor diet. It's amazing what you can do when you're just all you do to a person
is clean up their diet, getting them eating better and doing a little bit of exercise and thinking
better about themselves and taking responsibility and decreasing their medications that they're taking.
How the body can respond in healing can take place without buying a whole bunch of supplements or
having to do anything else. So start with what you can do, I guess, is the way to do it.